do you want to lead people into the
wilderness
[Laughter]
how do you spend your working day
a horse trainer
[Applause]
it's done if you guys know much about me
I am a fiend for ketamine
it's been a pretty short supply recently
there's some supply chain issues
wow so a horse trainer what's what's the
name of the best horse you train
Chiron
c-h-y-r-o-n why are you disagreeing
what's your what's your qualification
what do you do are you a horse in a
man's skin they've been
no
just
or just a husband yeah
K-Y it's we've moved past that now
um what what's what's your vocation what
do you do oh my God you're a guide
a guide
is this what the what the [__] is that
guys the People Into the Wilderness you
guide People Into the Wilderness
I am a serial killer Chris
I murder Folk you guide people so you're
like you're like a white Sherpa what's
the
[Laughter]
to to where and who do you guide
humans yeah yeah [__] definite serial
killer
humans Flesh and Blood humans
that's not a job that we're told when
we're kids it's not like you know you
can be a guide yeah you were just the
back of the classroom sharpening the
scissors and they were like do you want
to lead people into the wilderness
[Laughter]
you can correct me yes
it's not a job that English people are
told as a job yeah
that's good to know minnesotans can be a
guy well thank you for that and so the
person who sat did he lead you here is
that what happened
I I was just obviously I was just in
Minneapolis and I
so what what do you do
you own a healthcare business oh so well
uh yeah let's see
um
what type of healthcare business
we care okay cool growing up did you
want to make money off sick people
no if there weren't people like him then
there wouldn't be a Healthcare System
would there Chris
don't [__] Canada manager
what did you want to be grown up
a baseball star [__] yeah and then you
were like let's be realistic
there's a lot of sick people and they
need they need to pay okay well
it's lovely to get to know you three
um I I wanna no you've been generous
giving me your time growing up I wanted
to be a freestyle rapper that was my my
passion and I I managed to achieve that
so uh DJ do me a favor drop that beat
and we'll uh we'll we'll immortalize
these lovely people uh in a freestyle
rap as I said a rat made up on the spot
uh and don't don't worry it won't be as
[__] as you're expecting it to be but
we'll start with my my Gentleman there
you've got your shirt unburned quite a
bit as well it's nice yeah cool cool
slightly bold on the dawn got the head
scalp bear but your unbuttoned shirt
like the hair down there you can check
it out I'm so Grizzy like a bear so
furry I was so young so early I'm
aspiring to be like Mickey man or Babe
Ruth no call that I can't handle serve
it up with the Curve maybe a slider I
see that athletic passion inside you
maybe short stop that's the position but
you grow up age then you feel the
admission you're like I need to admit
people to emergency room and get the
cash coming in I consume take these
pills we can see the primary care
provided the PCP not PCP that's a drug
that we know a different time make a
pretty penny though and my bro over here
so why died he's in Minnesota alike one
day I'll be your guide enter the
Wilderness and then a hide everybody
people be so snide British people are
like that's not a job get something
proper you horrible slob you're off
there in Minnesota so nice like oh
nearby Margo my advice in North Dakota
and other little things the ice in the
winter you know it's things you like to
take people by the hand and say follow
me you'll understand we're going to
explore the Wilderness go over here now
get undressed I've got a gun yeah all my
days I'm Gonna Make You Dig your own
grave get down in the dirt and then I'll
shoot you back to civilization so cute
to be a little guide come on my tours
when I was a boy yes I adored one day I
would do this it would be crazy and then
I'd go out and find a lady who would it
be you of course I saw you over there
patting a horse
I'm ever so lonely but I like to stroke
my pony so sweet look at my wet hand
you're a small pony yes from Shetland
that's the name it's a no-brainer you
make them crop round that's the nice
horse trainer Chiron the one that makes
you grin because it's the one that
shares with you it's ketamine
thank you